okay hogwarts legacy fans just when you
thought we had broken down all of the
news that we possibly could we'd taken a
look at every single frame of that
gameplay trailer you find something that
you missed but in this case it was
actually another youtube creator not
sure how to pronounce it i think maybe
agito it's a-g-i-t-o i'll link their
video down in the description below but
full credit goes to them for finding
this i cannot believe this much time
went by you guys and seemingly everybody
i don't know that i have seen this
anywhere else for months i mean this
state of play trailer came out back in
march right guys so the fact that we
have just now found something that to my
knowledge is completely new is just
insane so what exactly is it well if you
go to about 612 you can test this
yourself in the official hogwarts legacy
stay to play gameplay trailer go to
around the 612 mark click on the little
gear icon and make sure you slow it down
to about 0.25 speed and then play it
then when you start to play it look in
the bottom right corner and just as it
kind of goes from 613 to 614 you will
see a brief glimpse a very brief glimpse
of what appears to be a hud for the
spells in hogwarts legacy so if you're
wondering why this looks so sort of
strange with the coloring and everything
here it's because a gito took that shot
and then by adjusting things like the
saturation and exposure you can actually
pull out certain parts that you couldn't
see as well before now i tested this
myself this is not anything photoshopped
because when i first thought i was like
oh this is totally photoshopped in it's
not real at all somebody would have seen
this by now right no i was totally wrong
it is absolutely 100 legit you can go
right now and test this yourself i
actually screenshotted the exact moment
threw it into affinity photo and then
started playing around with the exposure
myself and exactly i mean you can see
these four little icons right here the
one on the right you really can't make
out what it is i assume it's either an
open space or just they transition away
from it so quickly it never even has
time to render so we can't see what that
one is unless you look at maybe the
little white piece at the bottom like
maybe that's a spell they don't have
unlocked yet maybe they're working to
earn it or something i'm not sure i
think it's far more likely that it just
transitioned away and we either couldn't
see what that one is or they just don't
have anything in that slot yet so if you
look at the other three though i think
it's pretty clear what these spells are
the one at the bottom has to be accio
right it's got the little icon of the
hand and then the arrow pointing back
toward the hand we have seen accio
featured in a number of spots throughout
the gameplay trailer we know that one's
going to be in and we know that it's
going to be used to pull things toward
the caster the one on the left this one
could be a few things but i think the
most likely is wingardium leviosa in a
nice nod to the first harry potter movie
with professor flitwick teaching the
first years how to move the feather
using wingardium leviosa
and then you have the top one this one
is probably the one that i'm least
certain about but if i had to guess i
would say this is lumos it's clearly a
wand that we see right here and then
when it extends up it looks like there's
some sort of light coming out of it
there now to me the far more interesting
piece of this is not so much the spells
because we knew all those spells were in
the game but it's how they're going to
be used in the game i've been replaying
through the old harry potter games you
can check out my let's plays here on the
channel and one of the most frustrating
things about those games is how you can
have so few spells equipped at a given
time so here it seems at minimum we're
going to be able to equip four spells
and what i'm less certain about is i'm
less certain about are they mapped to
the face button so on playstation would
they be mapped to x square circle and
triangle or are they mapped to the d-pad
and then we press a direction of the
d-pad and then that is sort of our
active spell and we use something like
r2 or r1 to actually do the casting now
some of you out there were hoping that
you could equip all sorts of spells at a
given time i wouldn't let this worry you
too much because i do think it's still
possible that we see some sort of spell
wheel that could be used for quick
access once you start to learn even more
spells in the game i mean we've seen
this in games like ratchet and clank
where you can hotkey some of them to the
d-pad but then you also have the full
wheel you can unlock the witcher 3 did
this as well so i expect we'll see some
sort of system like that in hogwarts
legacy so i think that would be a more
modern approach to the way that current
games are handling it rather than games
of the past like prisoner of azkaban
which i'm replaying right now and you
can only have three spells equipped at a
given time and one thing about that game
is it does a great job with the variety
and gameplay so it encourages you to use
different types of spells but i'm
constantly having to go into the pause
menu to re-equip different spells and i
just don't think hogwarts legacy will do
that clearly we're going to have four
slots at a minimum i think we'll be able
to select even more through something
like a wheel and then these four here i
expect to be the ones that you can
hotkey for that really quick access now
if you're curious about seeing how those
old school harry potter games handled it
then check out the video on the right
side of your screen that's my latest
let's play for harry potter and the
prisoner of azkaban as always thank you
all so much for watching i'll talk to
you again soon